hello and welcome my name is Ross Ennis
I'm the director of CNS research at the
company selected corn here at the
company I am responsible for the
neurodegeneration research and also
related a business area today I would
like to present to you our concept how
we aim to decipher the spreading of new
pathologies in neural circuits using our
high capacity micro fluidics gutful so
first I will truly talk about our
company so select account is a
collaborative services provider we are
dedicated to accelerate drug discovery
and also research in the area of chronic
pain and neural degeneration our team
comprised of highly experienced
neurobiologist stem cell researchers and
engineers and we have a proven track
record of developing innovative in vitro
assays of enhancer session value so our
company is located in Gothenburg in
Sweden we have a privately held company
in we were founded in 2003 as the spin
hard from the charmer University of
Technology and intentionally we started
as a product company but then
transferred to service model in 2012 in
order to align with the industry climate
and the market needs and today's
presentation I would like to start with
describing and pathology is seen in
Ultima and pockets on disease patient
brain so what you can see here in this
image is our same you know psychic EMA
immunohistochemistry staining of cortex
tissue isolated post-mortem from an
animal disease patient brain and this
tissue was preceded by a fixation and
using an tau antibody in order to
visualize tau tangles within the soma of
the cortical neurons here pointed by the
arrows and also what you can see here
the arrow heads heads pointing it also
called tau tangles within the neurites
so this is our or to bigger pathological
feet
one can observed in a brain tissue a
lady from Alzheimer disease patient
brain and similar to this R one can also
observed in Parkinson disease patient
brain issues so-called alpha synuclein
inclusions within the soma he appointed
by the arrows or the neurites you point
about airheads
in substance and icon neurons so this
are to be killed neuro pathological
features in this neuro degenerative
diseases so but as you can see here we
have this new pathology features in
cortical neurons and substance and icons
however in fact it turns out it is not
only in this brain areas they can see
these pathologies in fact that is shown
in this light now you can see by the
color codes in blue for tau tangles and
red alpha synuclein
inclusions in red you can see that an
early stage just in the car time course
of the disease indicated Beleriand
years that one can see this apologies in
subcortical regions for instance in the
brain stem or in the middle of Regatta
so and during the time cause of the
disease
apparently this toll Kangas spread into
a frozen plain occlusion spread into
other brain areas and at the end and
that saith some kind of end stages of
the disease on come observe that nearly
the entire brain showed these
pathologies and therefore one is talking
about progressive pathologies in
alzheimer's and parkinson's disease
of course this aspect is highly
interested to to study and to reveal
what exactly is happening here in the in
the patient and in the next slide I
would just described a little by using
it let's say a schematic drawing on
describing here occurring hi positives
which is used to explain this it's a
progressive mythology seen in vivo and
as you might heard about as a concept
it's called the prion like spreading of
authorities which I would like to
describe so
eventually we have a healthy neuron
which for currently unknown reason shows
at one point pathological hallmarks for
instance accumulation of risk for the
proteins but also this is a affected
neuron started to secrete this misfolded
proteins and an important aspect of the
prion like spreading hypothesis is that
this misfolded proteins can be up taken
by axons which are very wide for neurons
innervating the primary effect on you
know so this is shown on dissa slightly
and discern schematic drawing and this
then once they this misfolded protein is
within the accent
it become axonal transport observers in
that case it's the retrograde transport
leading to the somatic accumulation of
this misfolded protein but however also
what it does is it caused miss falling
of endogenous protein in this recipe
near so therefore we have started is
like the primary affected neuron and
then this release misfolded protein and
which in the ends leads to pathology
seen in a secondary affected neuron that
could be late the localized at say in a
far distant of rain region so answer
what click on static on we have decided
to model this progressive pathology seen
in the patients in vitro by using and
devise and high-capacity micro fluidics
platform so our aim was here to be able
to do high content analysis of
pathological processes and
compartmentalized normal cultures but
also we had to aim to devise a system
which has sufficient capacity for
screening in the search of compounds
that modulate specific several processes
that i involved the progressive
mythology's what we have came up with is
shown in that slide so we developed a
384-well plate so it looks like a
regular 384-well plate however is really
forward plated comprised of 96 of this
year shown expert Orion
so what you can see here is a three well
system so we have a well one
well two and well three and these wells
are interconnected by microfluidic
channels and we use those systems in
order to culture primary but also human
iPS earner ons in the system and then we
can also as shown here in this in green
we can culture for instance IPS a
cortical neurons here these cells are
cultured for three weeks in vitro and
then they're filled with the constant 5
by 2 one point is to assess the
functional properties of those cells of
these neurons but also to visualize the
normal morphology and the neural grows
within the channels that is one
application we have used them that was
part of our technical validation
procedure just to observe if kin culture
primary and you might ascend into the
system another part of our technical
validation procedure was to assess if we
can maintain through the integrity in
the system so what that means is that at
one point we want to apply molecules in
in the well that said well one and we
want that this molecule or let's say
seed is only affecting the cells in well
one but does not diffuse into
interconnected well to so in order to
test it we did a testing series and
forever use different molecular weight
for us in molecules for instance crews
seen so here shown in the schematic
drawing we added after Racine into red
one and then we created a hydrodynamic
barrier by having exceeded warning
invert - and by this an we create critic
integrity therefore that means that
molecule invert one does not diffuse to
the to how we tested and how we measure
that so that we assess our we didn't
imaging settings invite you to measure
the fluorescence here shown in this
diffusion profile thought and what you
can see is actually that we do not
measure any type of presence when we
have in hydrodynamic barrier in where to
in contrast when we don't have different
volumes in the system then we can see
that over time there's an increase in
the relatively units of presence
detected in well too and that indicates
that molecules has been diffused from
where one into the two so what this
experiment shows is that we can maintain
integrity in the system over more than
three days without any fruity crosstalk
or leakage in the interval and this is
wheezing it's an important aspect or
need to address when using those systems
so in the next few slides I would like
to show you a case study where we use
that system for in vitro modeling of
pathological processes occurring in
Parkinson's disease as I showed you
before Parkinson's disease is
characterized by the spreading of
iPhones and radiation visitor this is a
patient brain and on cellular level we
have several processes going on here we
have axons
up take off so cause they're seeds or
misfolded proteins axonal transport
somatic accumulation and misfolding of
endogenous proteins so all these aspects
cellular processes we aim to more in our
system and indeed in the next few slides
I will explain to you how we have
succeeded here so what you can see here
is the description what the methods were
using in order to generate called quanta
mentalize from all the cultures so first
we Heinz Annette embryos c57 black 6
mice
these are 18 embryos and then we perform
the tissue dissection of the cortex and
then generating a cell suspension from
this cortical tissue and then the
culture cells in the outer well of this
expression units to to simplify that
here a little bit and for the next few
slides I will just talk about the but a
and well B and as you can see here in
the schematic drawing the culture cells
and they'll be but the well a is a is
without cells and you will see later why
we do this approach
next won't be there what we do is are we
taking fluorescently labeled I frozen
clean
we take your specific form it's a
sonicated preformed liberals are because
we know that those wanna see competence
means a king cause miss falling of other
proteins for instance moon america
fortunately so we use no dispersant
labeled seats and apply this one - well
a at six days in vitro then of course we
maintain fruiting integrity in the
system so we create a hydrodynamic
barrier by having different volumes in
the a a and well B as I described before
to you and we obtained the material
using for my experiment from stress mode
bioscience Earth's because this company
also provide a very good career
characterization of this material so we
know from the electron microscopy
imaging that for having really fibrils
which we are applying here analysis seed
competence has been evaluated by to
fatigue TSA so therefore we know we're
using seed competence material in our
system after seven days of incubation
with the seeds we use an operator hike
ican't an imaging system from parking
Alma and also the related harmony high
content analysis software in order to
characterized or motor system but also
described the cellular processes
occurring in his disease more so what
you can see here is a characterization
work we have done because we wanted to
know war on what type of sounds we have
in culture to better understand our
model system so we counter about like
twenty thousand living cells pay well
and then we have here performed in wound
site of chemistry straining using new
hand as a marker for neurons or GFP as a
mark of astrocytes which is shown yet is
image on the left side and we also did
the quantification of the neurons and a
society and you observe a of like a
one-to-one ratio about like 40 percent
neurons and 50 percent s suicides
also we combined under markers to
characterize more than normal identity
which we have here in the system and for
that purpose II I chose an example of
standing for park six and un+ cells and
the estimate in quantified at about like
75 percent of the news business system
about six near on sale indicating an
exit or II our phenotype in the of those
cells so there's a most idea
it's a glutamatergic neurons they have
new system so next year what I want to
show in this slide is the core party
meant alized cultures we we are using
for the system and all stats light will
explain to you why we had an only cells
in bed B and leiseth but a without cells
what you can see here is standing
compacted seven days after in vitro and
you can see better tubulin positive
axons which grown into the cell free
interconnected well and this axons are
generated by the neurons in there B
which we hear visualized by matter B and
this is a marker for to visualize so
many dendrites so what you can see here
is that we can really nicely generate
compartmentalizing on the conscious in
the system which then enables us to
specifically access and more neat or
normal compartment so we can access the
axons but they also can monitor on their
devices so mind dendrites and thereby
can expose the different part of a
neuron to different let's say seeds in
that case so exactly that is what we
have done here so what we what we did
and I described it before we used the
alpha-synuclein seeds which are first
need labels on we applied this to the
relay so we apply this to Zacks on the
net six days in vitro and as you can see
here when we wait seven days we can see
really nicely that the all the axons
nearly are filled bethere with self as a
nucleant seeds which are asleep labeled
and also then would be what one can
is that in the same time you see when
you take an image in the interconnect
there be so basically where the neurons
located which sent the axons into well a
so what we can see is a dis red white
dots and each of this let's say dots in
that sense represents sense who somehow
taking up the seeds by the accidents in
well a and therefore this indicates that
the axons
it contains the seeds and the seeds
become retrograde transport and and
appear in the cells it interconnector or
located well B then we also confirm that
these cells are truly neurons we apology
Luanne Starling so we performed the
moves that chemistry standing to confirm
really that the cells having seeds are
neurons and interesting what they can
see at that time here seven days after
vacation that most of the neurons or
nearly every neuron who has a seed is
located entrance area of their beef but
we do not see any cells at the far end
of their be so what that means is that
the entrance area of the least area
where the channels are present
connecting to LA so all the neurons in
fact having the seeds are localized at
that area but not at the find next to
understand more how where are they let's
say the neurons localized that project
from well a from well be into an a we
used to die
in that case die i and that we apply to
the axonal net and well a and as you can
see here this dye is also nicely out
taken by the axons and then we now take
a look into the well B again we see here
adults and these dots represent as I
described before I died I felt cells and
also in moves that can see
confirmed that this dye I cells that we
n+ neurons so that shows really the
position of neurons here in the system
that projects an axons from where B into
well a and as you can see here you see
most of the neurons
which are let's say transfer projecting
you know so they projected from their V
into that a are localized at the
entrance area of their be however you
see a like three individual neurons
localized in the middle of the of the
image field of their be and those are
also daya field so that shows that you
just understand the dimension here that
shows that they in the system comprised
neurons which are able to cross distance
between three to four millimeters so the
system comprised very long projecting
neurons and I think that is important to
understand also to describe the disease
progression in knowledge on our system
so next then we combined alpha synuclein
seeds so therefore as me labeled with
the die I seed so again we apply both
together we did a co-op Legation of that
seeds and the die I solution invert a
and we write it several times this data
shown here after some base and what you
can see is here on the right side the
die I field cells representing the
interval container ons on the left side
you can see offers and we eat seeds res
need labels or we observed is two
populations of neurons two population of
interval connected neurons so one group
is a one group of entire field neurons
they having the seeds and as you can see
here below is an example of four neurons
and you can see are three out of these
four neurons showing the seeds in there
so mater however we see that most of the
neurons which are dying I filled do not
have the seeds so that means that these
neurons they project over to well a so
they have the accent over there and this
exons are also exposed to the seat
however those neurons do not show the
somatic a combination of the seeds which
somehow indicate that the neural
controller using comprised of cortical
neurons which are not a susceptible for
seat
in contrast most of the other neurons in
that system do not taking up the seeds
but this is a very interesting point we
feel and that sums we are currently
further investigating so because we want
to understand which type of neurons are
capable of taking up the seeds or put
another way around which type of neurons
are able to let say protect themselves
after taking up the seat so those
questions we think are very interesting
and be pursuing more orchid to deceiver
this more in detail however a next
question of course one can ask is okay
what happens with the with the cell
having the seeds inside the soma and
what you can see here now what we did is
again the same exponential design
however what we did that today here we
use an antibody which indicate
phosphorylated endogenous I physically
in and then you can see here when we did
an image in the word a where we have sex
on an ad hoc sanal net you can see
there's a lot of alphas and green
speckles so indicating me of his some
kind of the presence of misfolded
endogenous alpha symmetry in within the
neurons then we wanted to know how does
the neuron look like and what they can
see here is again image that chemistry
standing that we used an antibody for
neurons so in that case um just to
visualize the neuron and as you can see
this new and positive cell here contains
the alphas in green seeds the fresney
labelled seeds in red
however also when we then they're
probably the antibody to detect the
phosphorylated endogenous alpha
synuclein
you can see really a strong some kind of
a Lewy body like accumulation of this
endogenous alpha synuclein
and that sir so that shows that this in
limes our concept which I introduced
before that the seeds can be up taken
there by the axons transported
retrograde transport and accumulate and
someone there they cause autological
phenotypes which are some kind similar
to the mutation interesting is that when
we now take an over be look on this
valve
we see and that is shown here is an
example image are you see here again
little bit highlighter on the right side
to sell having this little Lewy body
like accumulation of and the genius of
solutely but we see only few cells
having it at that time point so after
seven days we see only few cells having
this this particular phenotype of
pathology so what are the next step so
shortly what is the outlook of our
activities here right now we want to
assess more in detail the neuron to
neuron for the nutrient spreading and
propagation process so what
there are several parameters we are
currently investigating so one of course
using different setting models so as you
might know there different transgenic
mouse lines available for instance a
mouse lions available expressing a human
life acidity have an all expression of
those protein that would be very
interesting to see how these cellular
models behave in a more platform that is
something we are very interested in also
as you might know seeding material so
meaning the protein like alpha synuclein
can have different post translational
modification which has an impact on the
seating capacity and then it would be
also very interesting to see if that has
an impact on spreading and propagation
capacity also this aspect is very
interesting for us and that something be
pursuing also for in this presentation I
showed you data about like a 14 days in
vitro experiment I'm of course one can
expand and expand the extra into
duration so that's also something we
doing on and we can expand it to four
weeks or six weeks in order to assess
more at a the the temporal course of the
neuron to neuron spreading of this miss
for the proteins however we feel that
our concept to use normal labeling or
combine no nor labeling with resently
labor life resilience ease and also you
the imaging of misfolded protein in that
case phosphorylated alpha zillion will
help us to better understand the process
what is happening in our system and how
one can really then decipher the the
neuron to neuron transfer of the seed
material so when important question we
are asking ourselves and trying to aim
to answer is like that's a fluorescing
labor alpha synuclein seed and
endogenous protein aggregation occurs in
a neuron which is not dilated so what
that means as I showed you before we
have some kind of a primary affected
neuron in that case in our motor system
it would be centered i-i'll a burner but
if we would see a cell which is not dial
a belt but this cell has loosening level
seeds or miss for the protein then we
would see that is this cell would
represent secondary effect that a neuron
and that for in our opinion would
represent the more specific approach to
prove the premium like spreading high
pasta small eater in an in vitro system
so to summarize what I have shown you
today is that we have establish a normal
compac immunization approach in using a
high capacity platform by this we are
able to monitor cellular processes which
are involved in progressive new
pathologies such as the action uptake of
alpha-synuclein a shorter data but
axonal transport for alpha synuclein and
how the seeds and at the end accumulate
within some of the cells and also I
showed you data that the seeds course
miss falling or evidence for miss
falling of endogenous proteins here in
that case it was alpha synuclein and and
of course what you can envision here is
that this approach we're doing is not
only applicable for I wasn't lean on
it's also applicable father petrological
proteins such as tau or tdp-43
and
that's also something we are highly
interested in however we also just click
here are what we can be evaluating in
our I wasn't lien model is transcendent
expressing a propagation so they I
talked about this before or approach how
we want to do this and also we are
highly interested is what happened
listen you're having the seeds this is
individual neuron having an impaired nor
the function we think that our optical
electrophysiology capabilities are very
suitable for that so we can really do
super here
however excitability and synaptic
communication and is that impaired net
system and also we interested to to see
and observe axial and and grown or
degeneration which is also hallmark of
our dis diseases so our aim here is by
using this approach is that we want to
sa several disease mechanism in one
native normal model so by that we
believe that our concept in able to
address fundamental scientific questions
and we believe that our concept in table
farmer clients to obtain molecular
fingerprints of molecules and therefore
this is suitable for the decision making
along the drug discovery past so I would
like to thank you here for your
intention and feel free to contact us
for any questions you have or increase
you would like to discuss with us and
have a good day